yeah I guess the crazy thing is
the media is not even they're completely
ignoring it yeah I mean I I should say
it's crazy in the context of Newsweek
trying to do a fact check yep it's crazy
that ever that this is completely being
ignored when the video I think it got in
like eight hours 10 million views
probably more because I shared it other
people re-hosted it things like that but
I but I'm pretty sure 10 million views
in this video in a day
it's wild I mean I I think that I think
the consensus here is probably that he
was not actually lying that he is
telling the truth because even if you're
even if you were thinking I'm going to
tell this person stories that are not
true to impress them why would you tell
them the stuff that the people you just
said you are afraid are coming to find
you why would you tell them the stuff
that they're looking at here